this much the kind of guy it ignores the
rules cuz it makes you feel in control
right you're not wrong you think that's
cute do you think it's cute six feet
apart at all times both know the rules
nothing's gonna save our lives so uh I
refuse to believe that we're gonna do
our treatments together always looking
for ways to spend more time with me
don't tell me the one time you're
interested in some guy he's also got CF
I like seeing you like this
like what hopeful Oh
why did I pack anything nice Oh cuz you
always pack for a hot Hospital romance
[Music]
once your beautiful and brave check a
touch you
stay away succeed at all times
I got catches infection and you can kiss
new lungs goodbye
all I want us to be reviewed
after all that CF is stolen from me
[Music]
I don't mind stealing one foot back
five feet apart are you in
[Music]
five feet apart where do pg-13
you